hello everyone after that monstrosity of
a game in my previous video that immense
struggle between Tigran Petrosian and
Paul Karras I suggest we relax with a
nice fun game I don't know being nice
and fun this game is also one of the
craziest most poisonous games I've ever
seen it was played in 1981 between
Jonathan David's digital and Graham Lee
Jonathan David this doll was an American
citizen who later became an Irish
citizen who later became a Norwegian
citizen his father was Irish and his
mother was Japanese
so in 1981 he received his international
master title so I believe he was an
international master already when this
game was played and 12 years later in
1993 he received his Grandmaster title
but other from becoming a chess
grandmaster he was also a shogi player
he started shall we
probably due to his mother being
Japanese but I don't know it might be
completely non related and he's playing
against a feed a master gramley some of
you might remember Graham Lee from that
Darren brown simultaneous exhibition
where Darren Brown I believe he is
called Darren brown that illusionist or
something he invited nine chess players
and he will defeat them I mean at the
end of the simultaneous exhibition the
result will be in his favor and you know
the strength of the players vary from
feeding masters to Grand Master's which
isn't the first time something like this
happened a similar offer was also given
to last grand Capablanca some
millionaire offered them like a million
dollars or something to play a match
against both of them simultaneously and
if the result is in their favor they
will win the money but not the match
never happened as both the couple Blanc
and Lasker figured out what was going on
it's only a story it might not be a true
story but I read it so like I said
Jonathan David digital versus Graham Lee
and I would put a link in the
description to this video of Darren
brown where he plays against nine
players you can check it out it's it's
kind of fun and when Jonathan was
younger they called him tis the Wiz
which after seeing this game I'm sure
sure you'll understand why so Jonathan
has
the white pieces and he plays d4 we have
e six the horowitz defense e4 and c5
Knight to f3 with transposed into the
Sicilian seek after Sunday for Knight
captures on d4 and Knight to f6 Knight
to c3 and the Bishop to b4 the so called
pin variation and I really enjoy playing
this wood white as I was supposed to
play against my brother-in-law in a
tournament it was a classical game and I
prepared this idea ePHI which also
happens in the game gramley in this
position played Knights the e4 when I
played against my brother-in-law he
played Knight to d5 on what I play the
Queen to g4 would ideas of Queen
captures and g7 and allowing this Knight
captures on c3 but this is a well known
tricky variation for black black has to
be extremely careful what it does here
so my brother-in-law didn't go for this
he responded with the g6 and after Queen
to g3 we simply continued to play a
normal game but in this game that like I
said was one of the craziest most
poisonous games after E 5 we had Knight
to e4 and now Jonathan plays Queen to g4
and the difference is from that position
in my own game the night is on e4 and
now the queen is also threatening to
capture the night as well as the g7 pawn
so black is pretty much in this
variation force to capture the night so
we have Knight captures on c3 and now
white plays Queen to g7 threatening to
grab the rook with Czech and
unfortunately for black there are no
good discoveries here if you play
something like nice to e4 with Czech
simply c3 the bishop is attack the rock
is attacked this is beautiful for white
so after a queen to g7 rook to f8 was
played and here not capturing the knight
of course about a three it's a standard
theme in this opening black responds
with Knights to b5 would a discover
check from the bishop a capture some
before and Knight captures on d4 and
black is up a piece here but this is no
compensation for the for the dark
a weaknesses black now has after this
Bishop comes to g5 all the dark squares
around black King will be owned by white
Bishop to d3 we have Queen to b6 and
Bishop to g5 now completely owning those
dark squares Knight to f5 would a temple
on the Queen Bishop captures on f5 e
captures an f5 and here
jonathan plays at the beautiful
queenside castle with a lot of poison to
the position gramley decides he wants to
go for Queen to g6 he's he thinks okay
I'm offering a trade of Queens if the
Queen moves well the Queen can't really
move wherever the Queen moves I'm just
gonna exchange Queens and I'll be up a
piece good game for me but unfortunately
for him here comes the poison East 6
what's the idea behind these 6 well if
you capture the Queen with Queen
characters on g7 this loses to a
terrible set of events after ich after
Sun d7 with Czech Knight captures and
now rook to e1 with Czech you can't
block check with the night because rock
to d8 is checkmate as the bishop is
slicing all the way to d8 and if you
block with the Queen of course this is
the only thing you can do but you simply
capture the Queen and after Knight
captures an e5 again rook the d8 with a
beautiful checkmate the the Opera House
checkmate if you will so after each 6d v
was played and here we have rook
captures and d5 again threatening rook
to d8 with checkmate Knight to c6 now
the guard d8 square but here he captures
on f7 which check would be perfectly
fine for white to win this game and
black doesn't really have anything here
after the ponies captured rook to e1 and
it's game over
but as white played such a beautiful
game he decides to continue with the
beauty d7 now again offering offering
his queen capturing the queen of course
fails terribly
the queen is captured then rook to e8
wrote to the 8th with Czech Knight
captures and pawn captures with a rook
or queen doesn't matter again with the
exact same checkmate so after a seven
eight nine captures on e7 and it finally
seems that he managed to defend his
position but unfortunately that's not
really so rook to d8 now check
sacrificing the rook temporarily King
has to capture King Catherine's rook
Queen captures rook on f8 King to c7
now Queen captures night on e7 with
check
Bishop to d7 and out Bishop to f4
leaving the black King with two choices
King b6 or King to c8 it doesn't really
matter if King to b6 Queen to c5 check
King e6 Queen to a5 this is checkmate
and after Bishop to f4 check if kinked
sorry if King comes the c8 then Queen to
f8 check now the bishop is blocking the
Kings path to c7 light square bishop has
the Block in the queen capture Sonny
eight again this is checkmate but none
of this happened after rook to d8 with
Czech gramley resigned the game as the
following continuation is pretty
straightforward so yeah that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it and it's you
know after every game like Petrosyan vs.
carats in my previous video a game like
this is I believe always welcome I like
I said I do hope you enjoyed it as usual
you can check - all my previous videos
here thank you all for watching and I
will see you soon